aghion scorch are an inseparable pair
that just want to set the world on fire
together they are powerful casters to
control areas and dominate lanes Higgins
scorch thrive on setting traps for
enemies and lighting them up with oil
and fire focus on buying cards that
increase your energy damage and mana
early game use your flame turrets to
control your lane and zone out the enemy
placing turrets in the path of gankers
is a great defensive tactic oil spill is
your primary source of burst damage and
coats an area and oil any of your fire
abilities can ignite the oil and set
your enemies ablaze next up oil slick
will give you a small burst of speed and
leave a trail of oil behind you use this
to help you get out of bad situations or
to burn your enemy Indian scorches
ultimate its flame belch eggy feat
scorch a Molotov causing him to spew
flames from his mouth once the flames
die out he lets out a huge belch
knocking enemies away when playing
against scorch you want to bait enemies
into bad situations set up your flame
turrets in an area and harass your enemy
once they fall into your trap use oil
slick to get behind your target and turn
up the heat with Blaine belch it's time
to play with fire
you